こんにちははじめしゃちょーですなんか
2日前ぐらいにですね
あの神と崇められている私の大師匠親分
HIKAKIN様からですねリフティング
で何か物が届いたんですよで結構大きさが
大きくて見てもらったら分かると思うん
ですけどもかなり大きいなんだこれだと
思ってうわーこれマジでHIKAKIN
さんあのHIKAKINさんから
贈り物をいただけること自体がかなりこの
もう
嬉しすぎて普通にあの2日が寝込んで
しまう今あの我を取り戻して動画を撮って
ます僕と比べればだいぶでかいでしょなん
だこれと思ってよく考えたんですけども
これ多分ミソキンなんですねちょっと取っ
ていきましょうさすがにワイブンで貰い物
だからちょっと大事にあげるねええすごい
ぞこれちょっと待ってこれはどう見ても
味噌金ですねあのみそ菌って何かもう知っ
てる方いらっしゃると思います
HIKAKINさんがですねなんと
ラーメンを開発して
商品化したんですよそれがHIKAKIN
さんの作った味噌ラーメンということで
味噌が発売されるのかなちょっと詳しい
ことはわからないんですけども実物でかい
な実物こんなでかいのこれ全国のコンビニ
で置かれるってやばいどうやって
ちょどうやって売るかわかんないの
ちょっと実際親分に聞いてみます
[音楽]
あもしもしお疲れ様です
お疲れ様です
ありがとうございますいただきました
[音楽]
これが味噌吟ですか
届きましたありがとうございますこれもう
普通に食べちゃっていいんですか
[音楽]
なんかすごいお話聞いたところかなり親分
時間をかけて作られたということで本当
に
ちょうど1年だね1年さすがです
[音楽]
ラーメン好きなのも僕めっちゃ知ってるん
で
[音楽]
食べるの楽しみです
思ってるよ大きいですねこのサイズが店頭
に並ぶとはちょっと大丈夫ですかね
コンビニと
かっていうことでこのサイズがこんな
サイズが習ったということですごいなこの
大きさが大丈夫か本当にお店の棚とか結構
心配になっちゃいますこれ
いやちょっとスケールが違いすぎるぞこれ
やばいぞ本当に大きさが子供たち食べれる
かこのサイズ結構不安になるぐらいの大き
さなんですけどちょっと開けてみたいと
思いますすいません
失礼しますまずは中身何入ってるか見ない
とね
なるほどね味噌金のHIKAKINさんの
ぬいぐるみ味噌ぎんTシャツ残りは
なるほどね残りは中にたくさんの味噌菌が
入れられてます12えっこんなにいいのか
ちょっと待ってこれ入れすぎちゃいます
いやすごい量来たなあとはその梱包材
みたいなやつが入ってます
こっちじゃなくてよかったこっちじゃなく
てよかった親分商品化した時なんかサイズ
感見せてこっちのサイズで販売するとか
だったら結構マジで普通に震えてました皆
さんよかったですあの本当のみそ金はこの
サイズでございますちゃんとカップ
ラーメンのサイズ良かったよしじゃあ早速
食べてみたいと思います2つ出てるみたい
ですねこっちがまさにみそ菌ですね
ラーメンの味噌菌
濃厚味噌成分とか色々書いてありますね
まあ僕は親分がくれたものだったら
アレルギーでも食べます
絶対真似しないでください白味噌と
ニンニクの
旨味広がるやみつきな味わいってことで白
味噌っぽいですね裏に見てこれほら
親分のメッセージより僕は知ってるんです
けど親分も昔からずっとラーメン食べ
ながらYouTubeの世界で頑張って
いらっしゃる方で
ラーメンエピソードがほんとすごいという
か直接言うんじゃなくてこの第三者が
あえて言うんですけどもあの人はマジで
ラーメン好きですかなりなんかね美味しい
もの食べに行くのが多いの好きなんですよ
一緒にとんかつ食べに行くのご一緒させて
頂いたりした時もあって
iPhoneの下積み時代ねもうかなり
ラーメンに助けられたと語って
いらっしゃいました
でこっち
岬これ飯なんですね
美味そう味噌多分ご飯にしたのかな
僕が本気で考えたカップで味噌汁ラーメン
をカップメッシュにしましたダブル展開
いやこれマジで普通に楽しみいや親分マジ
であの近くにいた僕が言うんですけどマジ
でラーメン好きなんですよ
ラーメン馬鹿いや本当に失礼です本当に
すいませんでした本当にラーメン好きな
戦い1年間考えて作ったカップラーメン
でしょう俺ね結構シャレにならんぐらい
うまいんじゃないかって思いますよ
ちょっと2つ作っていきたいと思います
まずはみそくん
失礼します
おっとっと
もやしっぽい気がするのもやし入ってます
ねこれと同時にライスもつけていこう
登録登録登録
[拍手]
はい5分経ちました
完成ですマジで楽しみだってさだってさ1
年かけて親分作ったって言ってたでしょ
あの忙しい方がそんなんもう楽しみでしか
ないでしょう
混ぜさせていただきますね
[音楽]
馬鹿にしてるわけじゃないんです本当に
本当にリスペクトを持ちつつ
めっちゃ楽しみなんでもワクワクの気持ち
もありつつ本当に楽しみなんですよはいと
いうわけで完成しましたHIKAKIN
プレミアム味噌きん
濃厚味噌と味噌キンメシ
できたいやマジで楽しめそう本当にこれ
ばかりはいやあの人のねラーメンにありは
ね本当にすごいですよだからこそだから
こそすいません僕は親分だからと言って
事務所の先輩だからといって
忖度せずはっきりと感想を言わせてもらい
ますすいませんこれは先に謝っときます
これも事前に連絡もしてませんもう本当に
なんか気になった部分があったらちゃんと
気になったって言うしおいしいか
美味しくなかったかはっきり言わせて
いただきますすいませんここばかりは
ちょっと僕もラーメン好きなので1
ラーメンファンとしてそこは忖度なく
ちゃんと見たいと思います
覚悟しといてくださいご飯ちょっと後にし
ておいてまずはラーメンでしょう親分
お手並み拝見いただきます
[音楽]
香りは
鼻が詰まっててよくわからない多分
めっちゃいい香りがする味噌の親分行き
ますよいいですね僕にゲフティングした
ことを後悔しても知りませんよいきますよ
いただきます
[音楽]
ごちそうさまでした
いやすいません
正直な感想を言わせてもらいます
todayisポイント
[拍手]
うまいです
ちょっと待って普通に
止まんなくなっちゃったこれマジでネタ
じゃない方の上手いやつだ
なんて言うんでしょうやっぱ白味噌って
ちょっと癖がある味噌なんですけれども
なんかね多分親分の配慮が感じられました
どぎつい味噌じゃないというかもう誰でも
おいしく食べられるレベルの味噌すごい
万人受けする誰でもおいしいって思える
なんか白味噌の加減でしたあとにんにくも
ねやっぱニングって言うとこの
ニンニクの匂いとかっていうイメージどう
してもあると思うんですけどもここもね
いい調整入ってます本当にほのかに
ニンニクの香りがするぐらい
絶妙に味のアクセント落としてニンニクが
入ってるレベルなのでそんなに気になら
ないです多分なんですけどやっぱコンビニ
に出すということで親分のかなりその
みんなに食べてもらえるような味の配慮
多分結構ですねそのぶっ飛んだ味がバーン
て好きだったりするんですけどもなんか
そのみんなに食べてもらいたいっていう
意図コンビニ展開するってことはっていう
これね人を選ばず美味しく食べれるん
だろうなって思いましたほんと感想これ
マジで自分で言ってますからね
HIKAKINさんのみそ金の動画もまだ
見てないですし他のなんか
YouTuberの禊の動画を見てない今
ほんと結構自分の口で話したプラス
HIKAKINさんから聞いたことを話し
ていや僕ですねラーメン
好きって言ってますけども特に何味が一番
好きかっていうかもう最近味噌しか食べて
ないんですよ本当に
美味しいですちゃんとそのしっかり味噌と
いうより誰でもお上手いってなる味噌これ
はね是非とも食べて頂きたいですねうまい
あのーおいしいのうまいもあるんですけど
も上手っていう意味の上手いですねその
ラーメン中の人だけに刺さらないというか
本当になんか子供とかでも楽しめるような
味わいでした上手です本当にいやなんか
親分のすごい思いを感じてちょっとウルっ
ときましたじゃ続いて飯の方を食べたいと
思います
飯も出したのねちょっと時間を置くと結構
ドロッとしておいしそうですねいただき
ますいただきますね
ちょっと待ってよ
熱い暑いのでちょっと待ってる間にもう1
杯食べようと思います親分愛とラーメンの
おいしさでこれを今日何杯でも食えますね
このたくさん頂いて今日に全部食べますね
これ俺の意見ですけども個人的には
ラーメンよりメッシュの方が好きですこれ
やばいわ
わかるかな味噌ラーメン結構ドロドロ
こってり系の味噌ラーメン飲んだ後の余っ
た味噌のスープってめっちゃおいしいじゃ
ないですかあの味噌のスープドロドロは
こってりした味噌のスープにご飯バチン
入れてもう最後の締めで駆け込む感じの
あのたまらない背徳感これ味わいます
もちろんラーメンも美味しいんですけども
これやばいななんかいや両方おいしいん
ですけども僕味噌
危険です多分これ多分中毒者出るぞ
[音楽]
とりあえず飯食ってから2杯目ラーメン
行きます
[音楽]
うんごちそうさまでした何なんだろうな
やっぱ
米なのかな俺が米好きなのっていうのも
ありますけどこれなんかね結構中毒性あり
ますこれ
ラーメン二杯目いくぜこんなの親分作った
もんなら無限に食えるぜ
[音楽]
ごちそうさまでしたさあ次々親分から
もらったやつなんてもう無限に行けるぜ
ごめんなさい
[音楽]